[Música]
en la capital de tahití papit hace buen
tiempo todo el año en esta Isla Tropical
las temperaturas oscilan entre 21 y 35
grados centígrados
pero un lugar que necesita mantenerse
fresco es el hospital de papit desde
hace varios meses este hospital utiliza
agua de mar para su aire acondicionado
situado 200 metros del océano aprovecha
su proximidad para mantenerse fresco
cada segundo 300 litros de agua salada
se bombean a través de las instalaciones
y se vierten de nuevo en el océano
el agua de mar llega a una temperatura
de 4,7 grados celsius y pasa a los
intercambiadores donde el agua dulce se
enfría y luego se utiliza para el aire
acondicionado dentro de los
intercambiadores el agua de mar y el
agua dulce no se mezclan la temperatura
se transfiere a través de una placa Sin
que los dos líquidos entren en contacto
dado que este sistema de aire
acondicionado utiliza agua del océano
sus filtros deben limpiarse
periódicamente para eliminar pequeños
crustáceos y desechos marinos eso
significa que lo que vemos allí proviene
de agua que está a 900 metros de
profundidad Sí así es 900 metros de
profundidad para que esté bastante fría
hay que bombear agua desde profundidades
de 900 metros a 4,7 grados centígrados
para enfriar el agua dulce del hospital
a 7 grados
es el inventor del swag lleva 15 años
desarrollando esta tecnología
tahití otras Islas volcánicas son
ideales para probar un sistema de este
tipo ya que el fondo Marino desciende
bruscamente alrededor de sus costas y es
fácil acceder agua fría
hay que imaginarse que las montañas que
tenemos detrás en tierra también están
bajo el agua
Así que nuestras tuberías tienen que
cruzar la laguna por debajo de nosotros
y continuar hasta alcanzar profundidades
de 900 metros
la mayor parte de Los costos de
construcción se destinaron a los 4
kilómetros de tuberías necesarios para
descender a las profundidades del océano
en total se emplearon 31 millones de
euros en construir el sistema
el hospital lleva cuatro meses
utilizando aire acondicionado con agua
de mar en el laboratorio las
temperaturas deben mantenerse muy por
debajo de los 20 grados
hace mucho frío llevo guantes chaqueta y
zapatos
anotado alguna diferencia desde que se
implementó el Swat
Sí una gran diferencia
temperaturas constantes y frías
obtiene la mayor parte de su energía de
combustibles fósiles desde la
integración de swag el hospital ha
reducido considerablemente su consumo de
energía
antes utilizábamos unos 9,2 millones de
kilovatios por hora para conseguir esta
temperatura hoy utilizamos 900.000 así
que dividimos por 10 la cantidad de
energía necesaria para climatizar el
hospital
eso es increíble Es realmente un gran
paso para nosotros en términos de ahorro
de energía
el hospital Calcula un ahorro de 2,5
millones de euros al año el Swap ya se
utiliza en dos hoteles Polinesios y
también podría implantarse en otras
Islas como reunión
[Música]